i would just like to say this off the
bat i guess we are
breaking news right here
joe biden's nominee groped me whoever
she is she groped me i was terrified it
was horrible i was at a party and she
groped me and i it's traumatized me and
it's affected the course of my life and
if you give me a little while longer i'm
sure i can muster up some tears
i have exactly as much proof that that
happened as christine blasey ford had
about brett kavanaugh
so i just want that on the table now so
the journalists can start digging into
whoever the nominee is
she
totally groped me
and it was
terrible and she should not be on the
supreme court
okay
we've established that okay good
should we kavanaugh
the nominee
should
and i'm not talking about boofing or any
parties with squi i'm saying should we
smear the nominee
dig through their personal life and
come up with some cockamamie story to
try to derail the supreme court nominee
i don't think we should lie
the democrats lied about brett kavanaugh
they just completely lied they made
stuff up they had zero evidence
we have no evidence that christine
blasey ford ever met brett kavanaugh
and then when you move beyond christine
blasey ford to julie swetnick that was
the client of michael avenatti the
criminal lawyer i'm not saying he's a
criminal attorney i'm saying he's a
lawyer who also is a criminal and the
democrats had on their news networks
constantly julie swetnick who said that
brett kavanaugh ran some kind of
gang-raping underground
party uh
obviously there was no evidence
whatsoever that she ever met kavanaugh
that was completely discredited and with
christine blasey ford she never mustered
even one tiny shred of proof that the
two knew one another
should we do that to the democrats no i
don't think we should lie i don't think
that we should do something immoral for
a good end the good end being keeping a
liberal off the court
i don't think the ends justify the means
i'm not even saying
we should make the process a living hell
for
the
nominee
but i do think we should make it a
living purgatory i do
i do
i think
that
we don't want to make it a living hell
because we don't want to put ourselves
in the position of the devil
but we should make it pretty hot pretty
fiery pretty difficult we should make
this
a truly miserable experience for whoever
the nominee is
and the reason for that is
it is the only way to make this process
better democrats started it democrats
are the reason that supreme court
nominations are so miserable they
started it with robert bork ronald
reagan's nominee for the supreme court
they didn't like that robert bork
disagreed with roe versus wade
meaning they didn't they didn't like
that robert bort was literate and that
he could read the constitution so they
hated that and ted kennedy stood on his
soapbox and said that in robert bork's
america women would be dying of back
alley abortions and he was a racist and
a thisist and a thatis and this hideous
dishonest character attack on bork and
they get rid of pork now we have a verb
it's called borking when you bork a
nominee it's only gotten worse since the
next time we really saw this happen was
clarence thomas
clarence thomas who the democrats
attempted to
lynch
in the metaphorical sense thomas called
it a high-tech lynching for uppity
blacks who in any way deemed to think
for themselves
then they did it again
obviously to brett kavanaugh a little
bit to amy barrett not as much
they've done this a lot the only way to
make this better is for it not to only
be one-sided if the democrats can't get
away with it they might think twice
the next time it's like the bully on the
playground
the way to stop bullying on the
playground is not to never fight back
against the bully the way to stop
bullying on the playground is to punch
the bully right in the nose
and when you punch the bully right in
the nose you know what happens
you get less bullying
well it's the same thing here with
supreme court nomination fights
when you
push back a little bit
when you give as good as you can get
on digging through the past on
the giving giving these people the
second degree then you have a much
better chance
of a more orderly and civilized
confirmation battle i'm so glad you
found this video because i have been
told by a number of you out there that
even though you have rung the bell and
subscribe to this channel you're not
getting notifications when the new
videos come out isn't that's kind of
strange i don't i wonder why
why that might be youtube so if you want
to get notifications and the full
uncensored show for free head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe leave a five star
review to the michael knowles show we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you